[Music]
Paris Brussels nice stock Oh Berlin and
this year alone terror attacks hit
London and Barcelona loser voy Moniz
triple nationality tomorrow
Nora me an apostle said when I see it
letters important and further selected
Dijon Kumar moon only prism despite this
Europe is one of the safest places in
the world nevertheless there's work to
be done
the EU is tackling terrorism on many
fronts rooting out radicalization
improving data exchange between police
forces strengthening cybersecurity and
external borders putting more money into
anti-terrorism efforts and turning off
the money tap in France for example one
study estimated that the terrorists
spent 108 thousand euros to carry out
the 2015 Paris attacks to stem the flow
of funds
Emme peas are zeroing in on money
laundering and organized crime no loot
Allah with mercy even among criminal in
fear article yeah McNeil Huntley what
like him in elite organization say that
year ppl found it have filled a
tremendous half in Dalian could you keep
as far along on that ranted on
Parliament set up a thirty members
special committee to delve into every
aspect of terrorism and find an eu-wide
response to a threat that knows no
borders
[Music]